la menace
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant parler de l'attitude n'est
pas mon pologne encore
des pilotes des motos en enrayant fait
il a fortement vend donc déjà l'habitude
ou à l'étranger
mais la couleur ne m'en sens interdit
l'avortement cas de malformation de fait
de mal donc on les met fin ils ont peur
taignonnes que les foetus il a des
malformations les personnels et de
voyager ainsi que dans les projets pour
avoir de l'aide et son fils étaient des
randonnées des abstentions pourquoi
quand on jette les gants ont défoncé
giesbert
et comme de cet effet n'est fait pour
notre piètre saison de trop mais reims
est suicidaire pour horreur de l'aide
dans leur pays la section randonnée et
les chairs et les mettra devant la
pression de l'ancien pro borloo qui
coupe le financement des collectifs qui
lutte contre la violence faite aux
femmes
nous devons tous leurs demandes du
souhait c'est déjà arrivé que la
promotion de mort contre les violences
faites aux femmes parce que le rotor
apparaît dans ses fonctions
on en trouve que c'est pas dans nos
traditions mais pas à mon pic et pic à 3
et des biens la vendée 0,10 en 3d pas
l'origine de flambées de bordeaux nice
et ont pleinement ma vie at il décidé d
interdire l'avortement dans les tâches
n'étaient pas là ce n'est que le cas de
viol ou danser mais il en bonnes gens
leur barque et morricone aller plus loin
mais n'ont pas le temps laurent pelly
s'il ya des collectifs de solidarité
d'entr'aide on est frais de port pour
partir à l'étranger
on aide les familles à des pays qui
déclare que l'avortement sera gratuit
dans leur pays
comme la sienne et fait tenir tout la
djt plein de pays nous avons devant que
c'est parfois sous des nues car
aujourd'hui elles sont elles sont
torturés dans leur pays par le corps
médical qui a peur de représailles ont
eu peur d'aller en prison parce
qu'aujourd'hui en baissant qui est une
femme emportée peu long mais les pommes
on va rester forte en bo3 des grands
jours d'une somme aussi pour montrer aux
forts et dans le pays de l'europe alors
soutiennent les pauvres le lait et on va
pas lâcher
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
et maintenant les factures devront
chanter continue avec les chants des
peintures
oh
[Musique]
on remercie la mairie pour la scène mais
pour voir visibiliser les artistes et la
minorité de gens qui se mobilisent
aujourd'hui pour la rappeler les gestes
barrière match est marie dont le mari de
gestes producteurs qui démarrent les
basses l'existence ya déjà les trois
volets de régulièrement un voilà
on va le foot est née des champions
ouais
merci à voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
désolé
les
m
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]
voilée
ah les joies
allez
m
[Musique]
et
m
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle est soignée
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et moi
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
bell
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les allées
allez
avec
auj
ouais
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pareil
[Applaudissements]
deux colis coach ariel tous les volets
l'année la l1
là
[Musique]
à
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
dès qu'il a vu
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
merci
[Applaudissements]
le rassemblement
on voulait de perdre les styles
pour mettre en valeur justement la chute
du mur
on ne gagne pas le très branché
[Musique]
bords du léman avons eu des végétaux
ressort tout notre corps un jour avant
l'événement nous avons été obligés de
demander des artistes d'appel
représentation
on est vraiment vraiment désolé
[Musique]
ouais ouais en fait masser elle est
aussi une partie qu'ils veulent
présenter les siens
abbas
j'appelle à
à la tribune
ça va
si elle est là
j'ai ma banque autrefois si lé droit
alors ça va merci de vous les connaissez
déjà cherché sa mort ça va
[Musique]
vous chercher son fils est malade alors
je suis vraiment désolé parce que des
pro mac juste un manque de chance il est
peut-être dire après belhadj parce que
là j'ai appelé tout le monde d'accord
donc droit au logement
elles sont là je présente face à bari
sud et sonia qui vont prendre la parole
on appelle aussi roselyne relier de la
maison des femmes de montreuil
hélas roselyne ciel et da ça veut dire
monter sur la scène sur l'estrade
voilà et pendant ce temps là j'ai
produit effectivement c'est un passant
qui a consacré aux violences
intrafamiliales et institutionnels
c'est à dire ces violences qu'ils ont
dans le huis clos des foyers des
familles et aussi des institutions les
plus fermés parfois pas qu'à fermer
d'ailleurs comme les foyers de la
protection mais aussi dans les plus
fermés je pense au centre de rétention
ya de graves violences
je pense aux hôpitaux psychiatriques il
a des violences passées en prison
il ya des violences aussi aux femmes
fait régulièrement qui parle des
institutions mode celle qu'ils en sont
exclus aussi et qui renvoie à la rue
avec son absence d'abris d'indignité le
rejet d'algérie l'exposition à toutes
les mises en danger
je parle aussi des violences cependant
le silence des lionnes professionnels
avec des patrons qui sont effectivement
des tirs oppresseurs kifissia voir qu'on
n'est pas mais ce n'est pas que dans les
salaires ok je crois pouvoir
je parle aussi de la violence en lien
avec vous du vent de principe de
continuité de l'accueil d'urgence
notamment au 115
ce qui permet dans la rue trois jours
d'hôtel quatre ou huit femmes il a
reprend 3,3 jours au mépris de la loi
disent que le principe de continuité est
inscrit dans la loi et encore plus en
période d'hiver donc doublement tout le
monde c'est un c'est parce oui les lois
qui sont faits pour protéger
et femmes notamment les freins et
j'ajouterais les mineurs l'épisode est
gentil
déjà travaillé souvent parlé tout à
l'heure aussi je suis entrain de liste
et le programme et je parlerai pour
finir de toutes les femmes exquis
de la protection des droits d'asile qui
sont les droits d'asile qui sont excédés
se sont exilés souvent seul sou avait
défini temps demander protection pour
elle
pour l'heure six qui lui les médiations
les mariages forcés l'oppression veut
sexy
la lesbophobie et qui se retrouve
effectivement sans aucune reconnaissance
de leur demande de protection en parle
et dont le droit au logement avec marie
annie et sonia
[Applaudissements]
journal toujours la maison des femmes
devant travailler je voulais sa parole
bonjour à tous accueillez dû prendre
jours alors
vas-y pour le droit au logement va nous
sommes tous les types de violences déjà
une humiliation mais encore plus face au
logement
la crise du logement et attend beaucoup
de monde en particulier les femmes les
femmes isolées les femmes seules avec ou
sans enfants l'accession est compliquée
les hébergements d'urgence sont saturés
les conditions sont pas très bonnes et à
la rue saint-maur pire dans les
quartiers populaires on s'attend à une
vague d'expulsions ont reçu un intense
masquer la cause des pertes de salaires
et les pertes de revenus face au co vide
pour en parler souvient
appalaches
ces mamans avec deux enfants mamans
américaines
gens recommencent
[Applaudissements]
généreux avec les enfants a menacé
d'expulsion et
mal à m
givi donateurs avec mes deux enfants
avaient trouvé dans la rue c'est là aux
gens pour buter
exister pour que
les femmes aiment
thomas
avoir un toit et un toit c'est un droit
[Applaudissements]
l'important c'est qu'elle lutte des
seniors 40 ans quand on part de
logements et comporte deux femmes s'est
parlé de la lutte pour le droit au
logement parce que la vie pour le droit
au logement
c'est en bonne partie des femmes qui ont
permis d'obtenir des 300 watts partie
les actes qui ont fait avancer le droit
au logement
aussi les principales du tout sont
doublement victimes à la fois quand on
inclut à la fois de la rue et
l'agression place
[Musique]
en particulier les femmes et c'était
donc ça très important par rapport à sa
terne que voilà que les femmes qui par
leur mobilisation seront avancer les
choses
voilà des fagnes et soutien aux rebelles
dans une situation là ce soit au niveau
des femmes à la rue au niveau des trois
qui sont obligés d'aller dans des temps
dit pour être pour être relogées pour
avoir un toit sur la tête
j'en ferais tu sont malades
dans l'enfance ou malades que ces
conditions de des conditions de logement
et la décla crise sanitaire qui tracent
explose complètement mais les femmes
elles sont plus en plus seul fatal alors
vous en face aux marchands de sommeil
tu pour les exploiter complètement les
femmes et surtout en plus à la rue des
vagues possibles raisons mais comme tu
voles aussi d'importantes baisses ce
repli par rapport à la crise sanitaire
mais ça c'est être revenu on sait
comment ça va se traduire qu'on sait que
ça va être lésés qui arrive l'été
prochain et elle apparaître des
expulsions
dizaines de milliers ça va être horrible
la démolir les expulsions est donc là
dessus c'est important comme elles l'ont
déjà fait des commandes continuent à le
faire 50 ans que les fans se mobilisent
par rapport à savoir à propos au
logement contre les contre les
expulsions pour le droit au logement dal
crise et la garde toutes et tous
et là y'a le 27 mars j'en ai promis les
nations qui est une journée de
mobilisation européenne pour le droit au
logement un petit peu partout yann et là
des manifestations s'organisent à berlin
la mobilisation des habitants a permis
de faire réellement baisser les loyers
sont grandes victoires
kigali au niveau européen a récemment
lyon aussi si on peut le faire ça sera
avec les femmes et les femmes qui seront
encore une fois en première ligne de
sept buts et donc le 27 mars rendez-vous
15 heures chacun merci
[Applaudissements]
c
mais la vie
les collections permanentes pour aider à
sortir des pavés de la rue pour
permettre à des mains de ce contrôle de
routine et antoine seux visibiliser mais
ce que des bonnes sont invisibles
vous ne voyez pas dans l'avion general
ou très peu quels sont les métiers des
relations qu'elle se déclinaient
c'est à dire de survivre donc voilà donc
ça va je suis vraiment désolé de
j'avais peur de les condamner pour la
chose on nous saoule à 20 h les
centres-villes cgt espère dimanche pour
la retrouver
chossat graves sur les oiseaux et
l'association donc le rappel entre les
champions de cette nouvelle star a lancé
une pétition
envoyée
[Musique]
très belle partie du réseau hta
bénévoles voilà
[Musique]
parce que le 27 mars bonsoir seront
pièce aussi avec droit au logement
oui exactement bt trop de sport alors
j'attends à côté mais pardon
ma maison des hommes montreuil
est ce qu'elle est dans l était pas dupe
ce qu'a déjà non la maison départ contre
moi
vivre ici j'en profite pour demander que
les copies de la chorale veuille bien se
rapprocher de l'estrade
voilà
ouais
dans les
on est sur autre chose
[Musique]
bon
alors l habitat décent
en train
alors j'en profite peut-être comprends
que ma parole sur les familles de rente
non
d'accord elle est d'accord donc
chez les messieurs nous devions avoir
aujourd'hui
une jeune femme enceinte je côte
d'ivoire vient été débouté de sa demande
de droit d'asile
je la connais elle est déjà touché fin
mars et un gros problème
y aller pas venu jusqu'ici je crois
aussi qu'elles craignaient
bon côté on a parole devant tout le
monde je mets juste témoigner pour un
départ proche de celle que je rencontre
régulièrement diaries de l'afrique
subsaharienne très souvent en ayant fui
l'excision les mariages forcés
pour essayer de mettre à l'abri avec el
orfi qui s'en voit aussi est actif
dans lesquels elle n'arrive pas à mettre
de la protection suffisamment et d'y en
la vivant en france se retrouve devant
un dédain de la justesse ministre a dit
au times ont énormément de mal à
comprendre les rouages d'exclusion et
surtout pourquoi on ne prend pas en
compte leurs demandes de protection là
où elles subissent auditivement ce qu'on
pourrait parler des pratiques
coutumières
mais ils sont la caf aux gens dit
qu'elle protège les femmes justement
d'hygiène demander l'asile revenir en
tout cas moi je témoigne actuellement
on sentait pas menacé
temps-mort 3 n'est actuellement et c'est
pas que l'on vivait comme abidal el
chammah trouve n'importe quel prédateurs
pour essayer de trouver un toit pour se
loger
et quand elle va chercher ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure elles se retrouvent
ils fois à l'hôtel ils jouaient dehors
masi touch qui avec ça elle va c'est pas
mal elle vient aussi de voir une chance
bien de toute la région parisienne et la
gaine toute la région parisienne alors
qu'elle va toucher à bichât elle fait
étrange est absolument invraisemblable
elle n'est pas si on voit que son bébé
sera d
des mises à l'abri encore dans le sens
gaz parce qu'elle sera pas avec un dd
ça tout le temps et pour toutes les
femmes qui nous arrive
en ayant jeu
dites de parcours qu'eux
produits
donc puisque jamais elle aurait volé
témoigner pour vous diraient les données
demandées en france là j pour elle c'est
fi sync est en tort au pays aidant à la
peur qui lui arrive est arrivé à m
une quête à l'ère coloniale sommes déjà
en train de demander
elle va naître
[Applaudissements]
alors
les patrons de la maison des femmes de
montreuil et elle chante elle l'a
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non mais je crois que je suis désolé on
aurait vraiment voulu témoignages des
maisons des femmes de papier montreuil
voilà tout ça par l'aviation pas là
je ferai donc s'arrêtera ce genre à
parler des barrages alpins
à la maison des plaintes contre guy
bonnet on est brillante
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à toutes et à tous les femmes subissent
presseurop par des hommes violents
dans les maisons de la peine obolon les
injures sexistes et sexuelles mais aussi
des c'est celle dont on veut témoigner
aujourd'hui
de la paire de l'administration des
services de la préfecture
parce que les lois ne sont pas
appliquées parce que des personnels ne
sont pas formés et tout ça mais c'est le
code du gouvernement
sur des toits la maison des femmes de
montreuil gauche mais d'une violence
institutionnelle à laquelle les femmes
victimes de violence se heurte encore
trop souvent
les institutions et structures soi
disant experts demandent une chance et
la gravité des situations vécues par les
femmes sont incapables de répondre alors
qu' il est prévu théoriquement d
il s'en charge adaptée
la mise à l'abri ps merci est possible
dans le 93
puisque le 115 géolocaliser ne répond
pas les placements les appartements
relais sont pratiquement inexistants
l'association suis solidaire
3 arrondis et sa durée
exemple à montreuil en moyenne accueilli
à bondy
et encore seulement contre les violences
conjugales et encore si elles sont
simples donnez moi les critères tels que
les scanners ou les bottes de pluie
tant qu'on n'est pas violée battue on
n'a pas le droit d'échapper
sera cagnotte de septembre à décembre la
maison des femmes a relevé un nombre de
dysfonctionnements beaucoup trop
important 16 mai pour la vider de
montreuil moyenne une par semaine et
encore c'est celle que l'on connaît
et la plupart lui rue léon-gambetta
hauteur de montreuil
était normal qu'en l'espace de quatre
mois a lieu censé protéger les victimes
il est refusée à cinq reprises
je prends très grave de les compléter
alors que l'article 15 3 despatie ville
en ville
et le code de procédure pénal interdit
de ne pas prendre place
normal
quel est son fils hier
olé
prêtre le rôle est hystérique
samedi
[Applaudissements]
est il normal qu'une femme se passer on
celui des crissements masque avant de
porter plainte et les bulles mais
qu'elle a dit je reviendrai demain et on
lui a dit quand vous avez des glaives et
aujourd'hui elle a passé la nuit en
cellule alors son maître violents
s'étaient échappés
est il normal que trotter encore d
pour les violences
olé
on a déjà perdu la vie
qu'est-ce que
essayer de venir l'essayer
sap est aussi quelque chose que la
police est capable d'entendre
l'accueil des femmes étrangères
problématique quasiment en majorité pas
de traducteur lit de traductrice
enfin discriminant femme arabe accueilli
peur ouais mais chez les roms ces
coffrets dit
c'est normal
votre place mais pourquoi vous ne paraît
pas si vous êtes là depuis dix ans
on a aussi scellé vol quand la maison
est fait ressentir
[Applaudissements]
on revoit la copie votre place est mal
faite pour commencer
on ne peut pas prendre rendez vous pour
une classe rouge alors qu'on fait pour
voir des loups
juste pour une carte bleue
il ya pas de table faut trancher d'aider
les femmes à 24 dans la salle deux
tentes noires gloucester debout dans
l'escalier avant d'entrer
l'actuel en géorgie des pleurs explique
les familles ont bossé et comptait
proposer bondoux et les yeux qui lui est
donné sur qu'elles ont compris qu'ils
empochent non
chaque c'est pour les femmes c'est
tellement en dessous des effectifs et on
ne met plus se présenter sans l'accueil
sans réquisition alors qu'ils jugent que
la dinde département des femmes elle est
sans réponse
oui
les sélectives merci c'est l'unité
médico judiciaire qui permet le chypre
et avec arme au bape a dit des
interruptions totales de travail
merci travaille bien
et qui donne l'ampleur des grandes
qu'elles soient physiques
écologique gynécologie tout le disons
et ce chiffre-là il est essentiel quand
on se présente et
après devant le tribunal parce que ça
reconnaît les
violence l'un d'eux on est fan de
montreuil déplore le manque de
connaissances et d'application de la loi
il est trop de cols italie et dans sa
labellisation de la culture
violent
et se pose vraiment vraiment la question
du racisme le départ au sein de la
police nationale
[Applaudissements]
et
pour leur travail correctement et orques
des femmes de se repaître tout accueilli
on dénombre de la loi c'est la loi
républicaine des qualifs les deux
prennent aux occasions
soir est bafouée et voilà
m
[Applaudissements]
non
-
on va aller beaucoup parce que j'ai pris
la parole beaucoup d'hommes c'est pas
facile pour elle ce projet dont j'ai
perdu la voix je suis dit un mot moi je
suis militant féministe algérienne j'ai
dû quitter comme c'était pas facile pour
les pénis est toujours pas facile mais
il donne accès la révolte la résolution
chacun commun d'un homme qui donne de
l'espoir
ça va être difficile parce qu'au coeur
du pouvoir
au delà des islamistes aux de lancer les
mentalités archaïques consommatrices qui
bloque équipe l'autre équipe lot
longuement les attentes réelles
j'ai deux semaines le double triple
pampa ça c'est par rapport à ce qui ce
passe là bas j'ai pensé pour relier tout
à l'heure la ti ne barre l appel à
l'apache
peut-être que beaucoup vont se retrouver
et arrêter de bain par un port algérien
qui se dit démontrable et qui est
soutenu par ma grand
[Applaudissements]
la vie des femmes algériennes
quand on est arrivé c'était pas très à
la mode
nous avons trouvé les féministes avec
nous j'ai pensé pour maya surduts dit
c'est pas pour mariani mathieu les
féministes n'ont pas demandé ni notre
religion ni notre portefeuille un lcd
solidaires avec nous sans se poser
aucune question
[Applaudissements]
leur solidarité leur solidarité avec tes
jusqu'à monter une association qui
s'appelle pluriel algérie qui a été le
bon animé et dirigé par maya surduts et
partant de campi tu cette matière
première la combine pour montrer
l'importance de la lutte internationale
quand il fallait se fait battre en
tunisie au ganis temps si on réagit pas
à paris ou en italie personne ne parlera
d'elle c'est important et je termine
vraiment pour ceux qui veulent
culpabiliser c'était courant politique
qui vont vous dire oui vous avez pu me
disent vous êtes vous êtes limite
raciste l'immigration j'ai envie de leur
répondre
chez les féminines
dix ans avec les sans papiers c'est les
bénéfices
[Applaudissements]
elles ont toujours trouvé à côté
je suis gay
ils ne sont jamais demandé ni leur
religion
et leurs croyances
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
prévenir dit la lutte féministe partout
dans le monde de la solidarité
internationale
beaucoup sur cette place aujourd'hui ont
fait partie du jeu tous ses réseaux dans
les solidarités internationales aussi
bien de soutenir des femmes en
afghanistan tunisie au maroc en algérie
wire --aujourd'hui au 8 mars on ne peut
l'oublier
cette journée des looks internationale
tu vas me réunir de nouveau parce que
nos besoins
les maisons et à chaque fois libre des
femmes avant dans un pays l avance
ailleurs comme nous prouve tous les
jours
les avancées on allait éclater il
voulait bien des bonnes nouvelles en ce
moment mais partout même si mauvaise
d'autres points du mans est aujourd'hui
initiée en octobre tunisienne les
membres d'un collectif de vote une gêne
aujourd'hui présentes sur la place je
voulais dédiée sous l'immense je doute
quand je me nourrissais plaignants
applaudi personnellement j'ai rencontré
en 2013 elle avait à peine printemps
aujourd'hui deux reprises en trois
semaines tout simplement parce que ces
dettes ne revient pas
il accusait pour trajan elle été
condamnée à 6 mois pour sa vastitude
militante lgbt
puis le moteur du système qui n'a pas
peur de résister de sortir dans la rue
[Applaudissements]
emprisonné tout simplement parce qu'elle
a exercé un droit de s'exprimer
et de profiter et aussi de crier haut et
fort son orientation sexuelle son
appartenance gens
[Musique]
bachelot travers de ses bras de fer
monsieur jean tunisie
c'est un bras de fer pigeons
jouera dans tous les pays arabes les
musulmans aujourd'hui sur la question de
l'homosexualité
elle est condamnée par tous dans ces
pays les gens risquent jusqu'à trois ans
de prison
on n'a pas tenu
si j'ai un lien pour apporter pour ça
parce que c'est plus difficile
rappelons qu'emma flagorner elle aurait
bien là bas dans les trois ans de prison
et aujourd'hui c'est très important de
deux noeuds
pour pc
c'est le monde et libertés
droit de disposer de temps en temps
parce qu'elle s'en faut d'un van thanh y
aller at il été libérée c'est une
stratégie
et ça c'est cool c'est que ces libertés
là parce qu'ils préfèrent des moutons
ils peuvent les guider
aujourd'hui ont refusé tout remettre à
ces mentalités rétrogrades et
conservatrice qui veut
et à voir et à adopter des attitudes
non viacom en tout cas forme le
présentons des activités
donc
le défenseur international
c'est fini permanence il sort du nid
quand elle se contente
[Applaudissements]
l'encré non morale
les dents
vous attendez pas mal imprimés enchanté
avec vous
là avec sa chanson
c'est pas que je suis
ci après
et
[Musique]
la vraie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les peaux normales
c'est chaud
je n'aime pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hélas
là
c'est bien et mal
allez
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien
ah ah
à
j'arrête
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
et
un débat
[Applaudissements]
c'est
ap
ah la la
à
oh la la
non
eba
[Applaudissements]
et
les
elle a conscience
là
k
à
[Musique]
les
[Applaudissements]
602 euros loin pour la nation
m
[Applaudissements]
est-ce pas là
à
[Applaudissements]
voilà
à
[Applaudissements]
m
tout cela
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
non
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà
abadie
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
ça jamais
[Applaudissements]
m
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais comment vont-ils et ancien ministre
m
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que je fous là pour présenter
les lois cas recensés par le sénat
la polémique
ronald nombreuses années sur un projet
de loi cadre
pour encadrer
d'où les violences
ça concourt la protection des enfants
bien sûr
alors à tel aviv en ligue 1
sur wii
[Musique]
en attendant je n'y arrive
nous allons répéter sur scène
[Musique]
on idolâtre
bah oui encore
bazar et de prendre des cours d
à toi
bonjour bonjour j'espère que tout le
monde paye on en fait de lui mars
[Applaudissements]
trois départs
mais moi pelé journée de la femme
non
la gipa gp c'est un petit peu
l'effervescence concerts spectacles
expositions par aso syst
marc attendent aspirateur ou lâcher nos
salons c'est plus judicieux d'organiser
un concours de manucure mohammed vi
alors je vais m'adresser à la part 1
puisqu'il paraît qu'un tel concept
existe voilà
alors chère petite madame tu en as marre
de ma carrière s'écraser comme un vieux
flandre que le plafond de verre
tu commences à être un chou et la glace
et de t'occuper de 80% des tâches
domestiques de tout poil
chers amis que par un travail mais comme
maman aussi je souhaiterais vivement que
cette information pénètrent dans le
cerveau de tous les instits pédiatre et
autres présidents
[Applaudissements]
c'est toi qui dois choisir entre vie
professionnelle et vie de famille c'est
toi qui as giovanni temps à fabriquer
tout simplement à métier de malades
pas grave parce qu'une fois par an
[Applaudissements]
tu te justifier si tu apportes mais tu
dois aussi de justice
pas d'enfants
[Musique]
tu vois de justifier sur
trop longtemps et si
la lettre
t'es pas de justice
travail et c'est une travail pour cela
que justifier ainsi tu viens de te
casser du
je dois payer du 10e et rendra ses
petits kilos de rendre a dit aveugle ni
staline je dois payer le confort de des
protections périodiques
trois piétons l'utérus se payer ton
gynéco payer tashnaq
c'est pas mal tu t'en palestine parce
qu'elle fera par an huismes à cet âge
[Applaudissements]
dans la rue on de traite quotidiennement
de boulot de morue
deux chiens avant
bureau en thouarsais chez toi honte à
graisse et la justice torreillan d'elle
on décrète pas mais quand tu commandes
on te parles de tes enfants quand tu
diriges une entreprise
honda met l'art très long quand tu
déclares résidence la ligue
commente détenus je propose des lois on
te renvoie à des fourneaux quand tu te
bats média touch grogne parce qu'un
grand ménage aurait 17 janvier s'est
alors produit son père ce choix
allez bisous bonheur je pense à la
[Applaudissements]
le changement de loi
mais on va tenir en deux
les patachons leurs bénéfices
tu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand je vais à tous
l'effort comme attaquant jean ping c'est
la fin du diverses
je m'en fous journée la journée des
femmes et voilà pour ma santé me serais
content d'être là on a dû changer parce
que moi je m'étais jeté la scène où les
bardes il faut que la société va bien
[Applaudissements]
devançant sur la ligne
soir à la prose arcade de parts
alors aujourd'hui montfort les formes
des lacets elle est tout de même offert
au peuple sa vocation du fonds dans la
société
la sentinelle at elle ajouté la piétonne
où la société n'a rien
enfin on a les traits mais steve
espagnols les mois chauds cassidy % de
quatre pistes sa petite neuf fois on
nous demandait un report d'un drop de
groupes amateurs
le premier le premier groupe européen
leader mondial des bordels labeaume ce
fait rebondir au port de sousse en
europe devrait tenir tête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rien ne semblait pas pour sem 81 donner
le plus possible
cela ne suffit que l'on dit des mots si
mon panneau solaire
on sait pas ce que je tenais mon jeune
femme dans un restaurant mais moi je
fais pour moi confié moi même ça des
fois la scène du sport nous ressemble à
un vieux continent
[Applaudissements]
je ne peux pas c'est pour dénoncer ou ce
renouvellement de notre travail
je sais que je travaille les postes de
travail
des conditions de travail et le
violoncelliste cette terre anglophone
poussettes et les portions presse quand
je sors de mon tir en commun c'est dans
touch n'est que 8 mars
en grandissant
[Applaudissements]
les patients vers un autre designer of
the year et l'essayiste au lieu de
travail
voilà aujourd'hui rooney la volière pour
lutter pour la journée des femmes casser
la fuite
c'est en 8 octobre on obtient toutefois
la version
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas quoi
en fait bank moi je veux un avenir plus
drôles et les portes de chambres en fait
il est salarié tonnellerie parce que
quand vous savez quand le secteur de
l'hôtellerie
autre à lui seul merci bonsoir c'est
c'est une grande aisance relationnelle
et simon a eu des marchands
aussi
motivez vous sauter le magicien et même
en dehors de paris
donc voilà effectivement c'est ou 5 ans
10 ans montait dans cette accusation
mais c'est aux gens mentent et
consignations qui est fait de travail
c'est bizarre ça dure qu'aujourd'hui les
profs de chambre échange qualifié par
deux côtés
mon corps de femme de ménage de
l'oppression tonnes de choses elle
réside une prestation qualifiée pour
l'associer à denture majeure à la lutte
elle se bat également au fait pour
l'augmentation de travail et vous quel
conflit chevelure avec ton ancien de la
cousine et comptera quatre heures des
contraintes 6 heures mais quand rachel
donc s'annoncer quand je dis vous le
maître enchaîné de trois boules ou
pourquoi tu peux dire à vos besoins et
vos besoins ne sont pas effectives ou
que tu a rappelé sylvie vielle compliqué
bien cherché au travail que ce soit de
la famille clients ont maintenant du
personnel je pense notamment à alain de
jeu en fait qu'il travaille télévisé
matinal calé vionnet sur championnat et
façon directeur
[Applaudissements]
challenge qu'elle ne viendra ni pas
effectivement il continue été un conte
ignore en fait est que je puisse les
femmes dans la société
nous avons nettoyé les lieux sont
reproduits sur leur travail
donc évidemment c'est contre tout seul
quand je songe pas c'est donc tout ça
elle quand lutte et for its ou cd
billard c'est pour la d-league laine ou
le respect pour ne plus subir ça déjà
que ça voilà
jusqu'au dernier truc d'entonner d'entre
eux des droits des gens vous rappelle
juste un truc on avoue des cours pour 7
avril prochain du 7 avril
rendez vous devant le conseil de
prud'hommes de paris parce que les
femmes ne chante que l'on déguste des
batignolles ont déposé une requête
devant dos et de prud'hommes de paris
pour planter dessus sexuel au travail
contre le groupe accor et compte rester
à nancy le 7 avril devant le conseil de
prud'hommes de paris bercy
[Applaudissements]
m
justement sur la
jeanne sexuellement
bahmani
les âmes entier
et en fait on
pas vous
le monde
les aventures bon
un mais 80 décibels autorisés par le
préfet la fois
bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous ceux
que nous avons
merci nous sommes accompagnés d un
conflit d'une compagnie de trois
ministres humanisme qui défend le droit
comme tous les êtres humains
nous avons été rejetée par ronde année
toutes les héroïnes 95 tous les
collectifs féministes aujourd'hui point
travail formidable mais recèle
[Applaudissements]
très en colère vers 6 heures la première
de notre spectacle ne savait du débat ce
soir qui s'intitule introverti
inexorable à oublier les le pays boel le
vaisseau la première devait avoir lieu
le 16 nov prochain évidemment la date de
première et toutes les autres qui
suivent
jusqu'en mai 2021 ont été annulés
[Applaudissements]
aurons-nous quand même race un envoûtant
lee le directeur de notre terrain elles
n'ont pas été complètement annulé nous
avons été reportée au 31 octobre 2021
nous vous attendons pour cet événement
[Applaudissements]
d'autre part nous sommes en colère car
aujourd'hui complet me mélanie le
président allemand avec ses wapachee
sentent nous empêche toute forme de
représentation artistique aujourd'hui
on l'a su il ya trois jours
c'est de la censure parfaitement au plus
tôt quenum
la réforme de notre spectacle nous
allons nous contenter de présenter un
peu il s'appelle notre vertu et
inexorable empiler les relâcher ni un
bon nombre de témoignages dont les
d'autres sur sur les femmes ayant subi
des violences sexuelles et sexistes
comme je vous le dis nous sentons colère
de votre franchise de dire les mots mais
nous toutes ses balles à libérer tous
les jours évidemment de son fait de
travers le tiède mais aussi à travers le
chant la danse et la musique
aujourd'hui nous les tirons simplement
j'avais dit une chose qui est plutôt
rassurante quand on ne t'empêche de
faire de la scène
si les politiques nous empêche de faire
de l'art c'est parce qu'ils sont un
traitement conscience la parole de mme
artistique et puissante
toi artistique l'impact est que la
parole artistique changer le monde
sa part de laisser la classe sont tramés
n'est pas juste des rachats
une dernière chose vous êtes samba
so decker pour employer les grands mots
à la macro
cette zone des guerres ou des crises
joe pas les politiques
ce ne soit pas des armistices des
traités foireuse la puissance des
guerres économiques les lubies l'argent
le pouvoir la violence ceux qui sortent
des guerres ce ne sont pas les tueries
la ceinture les interdits la barbarie
sans qui souffre des guerres c'est
l'amour
c'est qu'ils soient des guerres c'est
l'espoir
ce qu'ils sont des guerres c'est la
beauté de la nature
ce sont les rires entre amis ou en
famille à la terrasse des cafés ou dans
les jardins d'enfants
ce qui saute et guerre c'est l'art et la
politique
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est entré
[Musique]
il a franchi très bon
apparu le temps sinon à l'arrivée
terminée
mahsouli sans ces plots sion sur mon
corps fatigué ou encore empli de
collations pas nourricière alcoolisées
fox et à défaut l'humiliation impossible
de l'oublier
pire encore
oui
le faux du lait elle s'obstine et john à
nouveau sèche et met son corps
ali avec passion
mon amour
si je concentre l'attention du
gouvernement sur les routes de cette
partie est enfermée à société d'état
mission tu n'as rien et udine le jasmin
avec un homme qui a tué tue toujours dit
sans raison en corner charnay mâcon
les rouennais version
à temps des promesses est exaucé
[Musique]
regard karnas sud
bg voulait
touché imposé
[Musique]
jouissance arrachés
nemo tegra tôt
des gestes menaçants
il tâte oppressant
mais pour qui se prend
dire qu'en risqué
[Musique]
mais steve ravagé
en sciences sarthe âgées
quant à quoi at-on peur
chen lei
battus
marty
souvient salut
retraite
[Musique]
si on enlève les ché
détruite
veillée jeux
sourire
me liger
[Musique]
parce que c'est une femme
c'est une somme
parce que tu
ça
et si on fait ça
mais j'ai confiance sap ag
[Applaudissements]
et quant à sabrina geniet battu mars rue
la vie est rude
survivre
bayonnais de billets est trop classe
ascensionnel
seul
parce qu'ils savent
c'est une femme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
citoyens
pas partie
[Musique]
besson
rh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai changé je vais penser
[Musique]
les champs
[Applaudissements]
jean
mentalement aussi
pourquoi vendre
je suis la seule la police l'aurait
priée de faire
il oriente et conseille pas
j'en avais appris lundi auprès des
pompiers
on peut aller à 15 ans
et c'est bien
m
car dans ma tête
hu
[Musique]
encore un voyage
mais gare à la fois les poteaux ce petit
yannis tafer 15 ans et plus en recherche
par des champions prenez deux
conglomérats du tout et les chiots nés
pendant que ses patrons ont fait leurs
calculs
alors qu'un pilote peut faire ce qu'il
faut faire mais c'est perturbant
[Musique]
tout ce que j'espère c'est pas si fort
il était comme un petit - technip
renforce ses capacités physiques
ça fait toujours passer pour toutes
après réflexion j'ai pris 10 de martin
picard
la cour de cassation censure jackson
tout cas c'est tout bon
je ne ferai pas des piètres je ne
voudrais pas qu'un quart-temps pas pour
les faire parler
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des cousins
je ne sais pourquoi pourquoi pas moi la
décision es pas que tu vas mourir parce
qu'ils ont mal perçu
je n'ai rien de pire que de faire venir
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas parce que
lectra
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'au mans series
cholet
et
je vais pour gêner
eh ouais
est-ce toi
le cas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
g
[Applaudissements]
non
c'est 2021
amen enrichit
elop au teich des désaccords des doutes
5 aux errances au sein du fait nous
verdon pas de fiche
que l'on considère
pas de bonne ou de mauvaise féministe la
lutte plus de justin soutien
je commence je suis très ému
domergue n'ont pas perdu mais considère
pas de mouvements peuvent tenir
à
c'est en justice
chan
s'écrira
à la volont de chacune et de chacun
d'entre nous
[Applaudissements]
4 3 2 à 1
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les prairies
j
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui encore
m
rodez
au sommet
[Musique]
le cours des dames
je sais pour nous
je vais vous dire
je l'étais
pau
[Applaudissements]
attention
[Musique]
et
bonjour de hauteur et à puce a
aujourd'hui nous sommes rassemblés à
l'occasion du 8 mars
je mets international de lutte pour les
droits des femmes et donc aussi les
experts du monde entier
[Applaudissements]
cinq ans notre association ses duels et
lesbiennes féministes agit pour la
visibilité lesbienne
le second c'est financièrement les
femmes victimes de violence des femmes
désirant aller en justice
actions je te du doigt un fonds de
solidarité lesbienne
pour les système patriarcal et
capitaliste hommes
prétendre que l'argent est le nerf de la
guerre notre monde
il devrait être chaud que celui de la
paix et de la justice
un monde où chaque personne devrait
avoir accès à l'éducation à la santé
à la justice et à la culture ans
en france la pénalisation de
l'homosexualité
je sais à projet eco mais le 181,2
jamais cndd a beau ne pas oublier que
nos droits et nos libertés sont les
jeunes à des luttes menées par des
militantes dont beaucoup sont présentes
parmi nous aujourd'hui et que je salut
merci d'être là
[Applaudissements]
la majorité d'entre nous a connu la
dépression du lesbianisme sans espace
pour vivre ouvertement et librement avec
trop peu de rpm positif faut
s'identifier
néanmoins notre imagination nos forces
et la sonorité nous permettait de
dépasser la répression aujourd'hui nous
lesbiennes nous sommes de plus en plus
nombreuses à prendre conscience que
personne n'a le droit de nous insulter
nous brutalise et nous discriminés et de
nous porter atteinte de quelque façon
que ce soir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mega lesbophobes l'enfant nos frontières
en lien avec des organisations
étrangères jeu rob lowe destine notre
association ses terres des lesbiennes en
difficulté en dehors de la france la
répression de l'homosexualité et du
lesbianisme annie encore présents dans
trop de pays au monde fonctionne selon
le processus différents dès leur enfance
les versions provocation sera occupé
l'espace public là ils doivent se
conformer au modèle viril de la société
patriarcale
à défaut ils sont réprimées avec
violence autre expression de la virilité
quant aux filles c'est dans le fief
familial que les tentatives de
résistance au formatage intero sexuelles
sont réprimés enfermement reprises en à
un mariage forcé juillet qui excédera
dans l'espace social et lesbiennes sont
doublement discriminées
et le son à la fois comme femme dans un
monde régi par les hommes
et comme homosexuels dans une société et
héros sans frais
[Applaudissements]
liberté égalité son riz thé sont des
valeurs qui nous motive liberté car
comment choisir livre paru sous la
menace d'être agresséé puisque nenê
égalité caraman sans égalité ne peut
garantir la liberté de ses citoyennes et
citoyens sorite et la vie de chaque
individu un même valeur quelle que soit
sa couleur sa classe sociale et son
orientation sexuelle
[Applaudissements]
leur vie des femmes et des lesbiennes
contre à égalité avec celle des hommes
gentils nous paraît évident de l'est
hélas pas trop de monde
parce que nous serons vite et sont
toujours plus forte que la peine
notre tendresse plus forte que la
violence de nos agresseurs femmes
restons solidaires pour continuer à
construire une autre société
ces systèmes de société violent et
destructeur dans la têt le capitalisme
un exploit jusqu'au veste d'explosifs
l'extinction de toute espèce humaine
notamment les n'aurait rien de calculé
le capitalisme n'est que joie notamment
le porc histoire et où le système
patriarcal et aujourd'hui on n'en
voulons plus depuis trop longtemps déjà
[Applaudissements]
ouais
breton ainsi styles très différents
entre les violences faites aux femmes
mais maintenant enfants
c'est complètement super on en rajoute
une couche
par rapport au seuil des années 60
et pas seulement comme le public est
toujours là
les salles et s'est toujours porté
plainte et dont le lecteur s'en suit les
procédures interminables 37 euros
[Musique]
les soixante dix neuf a vu notifier que
de faire appel à la justice 5,6 à 6,6 et
aux classes
abandon comme on le dit seront tous nos
campus législatives nécessaires pour
combattre cette violence
je m'entraîne que l'application des lois
et un diable pour régler le problème de
façon que d'hommes pourquoi parce que
les violences ne sont qu un moment très
cette façon globale et ayant eu qu'un
seul levier di mascio né en france par
les gouvernements la répression
a contrario nous pensons il faut axer
les actionner partons tous les leviers
de la prévention avant toute chose il
vaut mieux toujours prévenir de
l'éducation dans sexy par exemple est à
l'emploi du temps des amateurs des
élèves et des étudiantes et des
étudiants
[Applaudissements]
solidarité avec les victimes en mono
autorisait des absences d'invitation si
mon agresseur de ma vie voire celle à la
sortir ce sont des mesures pour 390 de
l'organisation internationale du travail
tu dois être dans le droit français
[Musique]
ils font plus plus plus à trouver un
emploi cependant pas le volet et la
location dans ces cas là
il faut des mesures spécifiques dont les
maturités de violence des gains
potentiels des violeurs et des
agresseurs pour qu'ils arrêtent de viol
est agressée et on fait quoi c'est clair
ici dans sa dernière vient de cesse l
autorité parentale que les violeurs
conserve car des droits qui sont très
bas dessus tout
mais pourtant on ne serait pas tous les
soirs au galop ce avec tous les
praticiens
quand on croit pas qu'elle est spéciale
gitonnière conjugales
les pompes à bras des tribunaux de mon
espagne jamie bell et compétence pénale
civile avait été magistral très hauts
faits et dieu m'a motivé tout seul à
savoir global -4 et on en a le plus
besoin et donc continuons à la défendre
[Applaudissements]
sonia et les copines de l'association
dessus non violente comme délicat
gynécologique
citons la plusieurs savaient montferrand
de l'année les violences gynécologique
et des chrétiens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui elle aurait pas du dessin est
important mais c'est un collectif
les lancettes magazine écologique
beaucoup de mes films et l'école finir
la baronne la source en pétrole
on peut débattre et les actes médicaux
mauvaises pratiques médicales
il yal'absence normalement tous mes
efforts pour empêcher la descente et à
mon éducation de demander l'accord avant
de faire un examen médical
rendez vous
ça
quand mais la vigne
ouvert du pouvoir médical qui est très
fort pour une prise de choix départ au
mépris des paroles qu'on est prise en
souffrance ça n'est pas normal
en fait mon tout petit peu plus sélectif
attends 14 ans puis
et pendant ce temps le droit des punks
en éclats me léger déconne on les a
toujours
il coiffe cabine
je vais
[Musique]
entre dans les cabinets chine
entendez devant les toiles évoquent
également des touches
galante en décembre à 10 heures depuis
les malinké
c'est important que tout voilà tous les
mouvements féministes motion
l'ancien ministre encore et nos droits
respectés ben quand on est en maternité
ou même qu'aux journées dans un cabinet
gilles & co
on met les bons contre l'espanyol 2 me
donne
[Musique]
pour les soignants de
la monture le montreux de la mer d'au
moins deux ans
j'aurai pour la mairie landreau
malheureusement c'est toujours en
attente
et non ça
cette pratique
elle et elle est très bon et très
dangereuse
[Musique]
qu'est ce tu vois on est lancé ce tome
accouchement matinée
est-il et les soignants domaine protégé
bfm
manque de bol
we expect l'exception venu votre
obligatoire également
papeterie
rejointe et où on a d'autres banderoles
qu'ils aient la décence des sous-hommes
phoques et suivez nous sur l'ailé gauche
toutes les bonnes volontés sont les
bienvenues reprises et délivré violence
médicale mercy
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non merci
poirier
avant le vol et le cidre
[Musique]
bonjour à toi
j'aime à l'esprit mais je sache ma main
sache même encore tanger distincts
les sages
saches maman de j'ai dit stop
moi j'ai dû pratiquer les avortements
les camps son chien
[Applaudissements]
à choisir
mushir revient de rôles entre 7
et sache comment ton génie l'état et il
travaille pour améliorer une serre
l'avortement en particulier
et j'avais fini ce qu'on est praticien
de l'avortement
s'ils ont pris parfois cheikh g15 qui
nous est interdite aujourd'hui en france
les sages-femmes orthophoniste elles
soutiennent apprennent des ministres
elles soutiennent aussi la grève veulent
au centre de la profession des à cheval
qui a lieu actuellement
[Applaudissements]
profession des stages pas elle est
féminine et elle est ministre par
essence
[Applaudissements]
parce que reste à chevannes ici et
partout dans le monde sont au service
des phares
elles sont au service des femmes
dans les choix d'assumer une maternité
opinews de la rejeter
dans leurs choix d'en maîtriser leur
fécondité leur sexualité leur fertilité
allongement dans ce pays les sages
femmes sont par ici ou là
visibilité en fait à visibilité dans le
paysage c'est ce terme
as as tu n'en fait pas assez payer
encore toute forme dans cette votation
d'où ils sont influencés
avec on est comme moi sur hier j'ai pas
dominante
les médecins les amis branis les
contrats marie duchemin budgétaire
et s'acheva son curseur de la situation
des femmes dans la société
yes on va traiter à
mais elles le sont les sages femmes les
femmes le sont aussi
nous luttons tous les droits y compris
celui d'apporter
merci
[Applaudissements]
on va accueillir maintenant mes poulains
compagnie de faire
[Musique]
est-ce que je peux mode examiner oui
bien sûr je suis venu pour ça
enfin tout comme je vais montrer des
doigts dans votre région
oui
des comptes une partie de mon corps par
l'entrée dans le contre et pas n'importe
où dans notre sexe comment peut-on
demander la permission
si je reconnais les gens sexuelle
d'application de l'examen mais
précisément à redon mais ne vous
inquiétez pas justement tir l'ambiguïté
c'est déjà la dissiper avant madame
on ne touche pas le sexe de l'autre sans
y être autorisé
moi bien sûr je fais ça toute la journée
je zappe d'un orifice à l'autre mais
pour vous
c'est loin d'être un acte anodin je
crois
vous avez l'habitude que les invendus
introduisent des doigts dans votre vagin
vraiment non bien je vais donc peut être
qu un spéculum c'était un instrument en
métal ou en plastique jetables dans le
multi de maintenir ouverts les origines
à vos qualités naturelles
[Musique]
c'est froid mon âge est une petite côte
jean marc métais de droit il est interne
que ça ne nous dérange pas qu'ils
regardent mais madame la libido star du
x je préfère quand mes patients sont des
femmes de ménage malheureusement une
question vous avez la mâchoire est
étroite
ça ne donne pas votre conjoint
félicite dans votre pilosité vous
n'aurez pas succomber aux tickets de
métro et mon passage très joli soutien
gorge vous est lesbienne
après vous savez ça donne des maladies
vous avez mis cause à cause de ça de
toute façon le mot sexualité ça vous
passera
ce n'est pas la pilule ou couché pas on
n'est pas en afrique ici n'est que cette
dame c'est un kilo par mois le froid 9
kg allez maximum 12 mais si vous avez
pris plus et on sait pas ce que vous
pouvez et partenaires y avait pas de
gros à auschwitz je vous ai offert un
vagin de jolis votre me remerciant le
pointu paris ces deux là votre col de
l'utérus en est parfait pour la levrette
et dans cette position que le dorner
marianne since la voix de plus de 1845 à
1849 elle a été opérée plus de 30 fois
sans anesthésie un titre d'expérience
vous ne connaissez pas elle s'appelle un
art cas où heath cote
elle est noire elle est esclave
elle souffre autosys tulle vésico
vaginales il ya aussi bâti à lui 6 et
marmonne avec elle bien de sa technique
sans point
le docteur six tours à enterrer des
femmes blanches soudanais fini les bois
je suis le docteur james moriarty
c'est moi qui ai inventé la statue les
deux pilotes possible gel anti robin le
premier envisage consomme à new york
et comme beaucoup de mes confrères à la
demande de marie jo j'ai pratiqué
beaucoup la lecture électronique pour
tentons d'établir ces dames
bravo à ces gens beaucoup les services
offerts je suis le toc toc c'est vrai
que la justice la journée plus tôt il
provoque des cancers les plus laxistes
c est moi aussi j'aurais beaucoup de
fautes je me suis découragée
[Applaudissements]
alors tout est mélangé on en a fait un
spectacle qui s'appelle spéculum on
voudrait remercier de tout coeur voir
sonia biche et tout
[Applaudissements]
cette chose qui est en tort j'ai pas de
50 personnes
la belle endormie des baux dessus donc
heureusement là je crois que l'on a bien
pris conscience qu'ils aient dit c'est
d'une violence extrêmement rare et fois
la tour on va préparer le dos parce que
le spectacle demain
le premier spectacle des vues a tourné
pendant quatre ans on était voilà sur
toutes les scènes de france
et maintenant on a besoin de vous pour
écrire le dos parce que
les témoignages mans
on va rejoindre à bord de la tomme
parole à libérer et de
à libérer
ce pénis et la création plastique ddpp
[Applaudissements]
la compagnie donc qui produit ce
spectacle produit également un festival
qui s'appelle le we touch estivale qu'un
festival féministe familiale et inclusif
voilà qui a fait que a fait grâce à la
situation sanitaire de grands du mult
mais on peut annoncer dès maintenant
qu'il aura lieu pour sa deuxième édition
en septembre prochain du 9 au 12
septembre à la cité fertile important
vous attend
c'est un petit regret
gallant c'est évidemment pour lutter
contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles pour lutter contre le
patriarcat et pour qu'on puisse enfin
vivre dans un monde plus équitable et
plus désirable
[Applaudissements]
me rends pas que leur site internet
comment smith ministre
ma chérie mettez pas de jury dans les
petits gars tiens on rentre dans la
poussière et la fumée
de prendre les français nous allons les
décorner je n'aime pas les autres
princesses
vous aviez en rouge avec des styles
maintenant les séries alors prends ma
propre plate tevatron
les vivres et les très tôt
les regards changent dans la rue on
aussi on nous parle
et toi quand tu es bien bonne non par
ici et ensuite le jour où la première
fois adapté touche j'ai rien demandé non
je crois des gestes le bus
alors on apprend à avoir peur on apprend
marque est de plus passé pour rentrer
comment s'habiller pour dépasser
commencent les craintes des camps des
arts cédé les trois châssis c'est ça
catherine
et viendrait d'une très tôt nous avons
fait plaisir tu ne sais pas pour nous
pour la première fois montré une vidéo
dans laquelle elle est pénétrée par
trois hommes en même temps alors qu'elle
qriocity leurs frais et lommel mai 2011
pour moi qui viens d'apprendre ma mise
en vente et celle en adolescente avec ça
la banque a procédé en tirera des
comptes en confiance
dans cette vidéo on continue en mai
ou pas
sa maman
[Musique]
eric besson défend d'être un outil
toujours janadi la police des surtout
surtout pas de points
notre corps tel qu'il est n'est jamais
assez bien jamais âgées dont on s'est
dit on sera acquis en s'habillant ce pas
pourquoi je m'en fous
[Musique]
babel je vous avais
bref du très beau un jour quelqu'un de
droit qu'on écoute soit avec un contexte
dans ce serait trop facile parce qu'on a
parlé à nos gars sont pas spontanés
michy
on a dit non
alors pourquoi
alors désobéi
pas vraiment la vie ça ld ensuite de
principe ayant démarré devant ce sont
les violeurs se font les clients
prostitueurs tu dois avoir
les très bons tant qu'acteur je le
prends et je tourne pour les enfants les
enfants
jg
c'était pour elle
[Musique]
à vauré soeur harcelé et agressé et
insulté les acheter en pâtit
osons rêver d'un monde sexuelle sera la
rencontre
désir nos fantasmes donc les airs sont
les nôtres aujourd'hui au monde
le record américain
seront libres d un journal local et de
la colonisation des psycho traumatisme
laissé la balle qui rend son style
et que bientôt ce sera juste
[Applaudissements]
l'aller
la cour
lorsque ces moments clés en main de
chant avec l'accord est bon
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
à
et
[Applaudissements]
m
à
[Applaudissements]
non là
non
à
[Applaudissements]
or l'hiver
non merci
[Applaudissements]
ça
elle chante
[Applaudissements]
enfin
non
[Applaudissements]
là
ouais
non
ravalée pas
[Applaudissements]
alors
voilà
la dizaine
on est prêt
[Applaudissements]
mebazaa
k
m
[Applaudissements]
ouais
lampard
tél
[Applaudissements]
bonjour alors me semble mal écrites non
je ne fais pas chanter cette chanson
bien et les autres centres dans le 20e
arrondissement a été fermée entre nogent
pour la réouverture
mais en face aux intéristes catholique
on n'aurait pas cette chanson et on est
fort sur la fin
dès lors si ma santé riche et la victime
est toujours peur c'est parce que cette
union
sans cesse repoussée
[Applaudissements]
c'est marrant pleinement jour pour les
hommes et les menaces et également parce
qu'un problème marche on perd demain
c'est par choix pour la santé chez dans
ce pays
c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
hélas
non mais
ils étaient 1
à choisir
c'est fait
et c'est là on revient
j'avais un an
voix des roms
pour de la moins
et chaponnay sanaa
non
elle aurait des mandats
l'inconscient salariés
regardez sur les péchés
ça
à
le démocrate
c'est beau
je m'en mêler
chanel m
les personnels
pas trop épais
[Musique]
c'est rien
ça
encore
[Applaudissements]
à
rien
bien
à
bayahi des noms
et au fil des heures
les autres
et
interview
[Applaudissements]
bien
à
alors chers
[Applaudissements]
ouais
non
[Applaudissements]
et
faire ça fait du bien s'exprimer
rapidement
[Musique]
opérant nous comptons buzet comporter
chanter faux pas devant t on vu
s'embrasser seulement gueuler
[Applaudissements]
rien
tout est là
m
[Musique]
là
bonjour c'est tout
sans le rallye des vins
vous êtes
[Musique]
j'ai gagné deux ans décide
la république pour aller les voir partir
[Applaudissements]
ces changements et revendre les droits
des gays
yahoo
gc
ce matin très bon chemin c'est une femme
at elle me vient et que le combat des
droits des femmes qui n'a pas de
frontières ici la bonne cause dans les
mots et donc c'est de voir maintenant
aujourd'hui l'histoire en france ou
ailleurs n'a jamais fait du prince
la route d'hiver non madame
marathonien okami je sais pas
l'étoile et combattez sac
soir au rex et ailleurs merci à
[Applaudissements]
en soirée
c'est à tous je vaux je vais vous dire
affolé manque à venir s'essayer
essayez de l'écouter avec le coeur mais
je peux vous avertir déjà que sa femme
finit par une invitation à la sorite et
si l'offre interdite et échoue et je
compte jusqu'au petit grain
concrètement viguier mère comme reste
groggy mais tu tour cela par le faisait
rire blessés lire les morceaux le faire
et qui est un lecteur intégré le moral
est bon à savoir
je suis devenu une enclume pour les
soucis ça va ça va ça va arriver là mais
dire cela mais 10 et les rythmes annuels
de l'éternel sa liste m'a fait sourire
akinori nova med j'aime des bougies en
cire ou les déchets banals à 30 ans à
venir
à 30 ans le rallye entre l'étoile il
aura et sa vitesse vérité sur le château
notamment à un énorme terminer seul
avenir meilleur
atlanta j'aime pas mourir ici de dos les
différents maux ce parent d'élève
cueilli tout repart à la meule fram tête
de nuire c'est le site est donc là la
liberté c'est avec lol l'union
de rossi je m'attire venir que reyes
atteint passes courtes qui reviennent
sortir on sent alors à sa voix l'arrivée
la semaine de zilina 1 0 et à notre
histoire
elle fut interdite les insa oui j'y
allais ya ça fait longtemps dans la main
quand il a servi leurs cadets minimes et
benjamins
aujourd'hui il faut qu'on dise que je
suis laisse des cicatrices
ma vie est belle la vie la série wonder
certains agissements
si la fraternité des choux notre joie
c'est l'autorité métaux
[Applaudissements]
karabatic au crâne
les stars
je dis aux français les maths
sa chambre
rebondit donc chez toi merci cap
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mon frère john c
et fight réponse
la première de caen fait
vous arrêtez les médecins les soignantes
des couturières et sans bavure
les couturières de la crise politique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
j'évoquais la tribune publiée dans le
monde parce qu'elle était complètement
visibilité nous sommes complètement
invisible aujourd'hui elle en fait nous
avons est essentiel pendant 7
parlons d'où la stupeur militants
le virus est pas inconnu
trois jours à condition d'être dans le
court
mais des compromis
pas de bluetooth équipement et
médicaments le souffle de solidarité
valeur du baril non
a lyon les pentes de l'etna
lyon 5e siècle avant centre
personnes fragiles
armés de l'autre
non
m
cependant on est des amateurs retraités
intermittents vous nous emmenez
démission de notre langue sur l'amour
tu parles
j'essaie alors les entreprises
mais le gouvernement et rebelles heather
gels de production
dgo
mais
n'est pas volonté
paul andreu matière
avant une tournée payer tous
tu as
on n'a pas tous les jeux ne se répète
une aire prieront citoyenne bénévoles
on aura une industrie locale jeudi
leurs fashion de localisation
reposera pas la suite contre l'inflation
sion
votre avis
longtemps mais tu m'as morrison
[Musique]
j'en étais pas
sa fille
notamment se retrouve tout le monde tous
les voyants
200 en vrac en plus vaste complexe uv en
cabine quand on fait des bonnes dans la
région d'être de france
on l'opère ses 80 mille par mille
bénévoles étaient un million de 24 ans
la communication politique glorifier
pour la distribution toujours plus
massives de masques gratuits toujours y
avait tant qu'animaux les moutures yale
non limités mais n'y ont aucune
rémunération ni réparation des dommages
physiques et accident mécanique ou avoir
répondu à l'urgence nationale
chaque 5 nous couturière professionnelle
après exprimé le besoin d'être aimé
pour nous et élan de solidarité les
[Musique]
professionnels nous sommes insultés
public ou de la moins peuplée même
nature bon ceux qui travaillent pour
qualifier la moindre représentation de
ta vie d'une part le monde